these are some of the last poignant
images of Li one Liang a doctor who was
punished for daring to tell the truth
now he's died from the virus that he'd
first warned colleagues about late last
year to many he'll be remembered as a
Chinese hero I deeply regret his death
and feel sincerely sad for him we need
to see if the influence of his death can
wake up anything and I hope he did not
die in vain he left us when we needed
him to fight the virus and he was a
victim of the virus too he was unfairly
criticized because of his work so we
feel very sad and regretful he showed a
responsible attitude toward society he
is honest and faithful so I think the
whole society should reflect on this on
social media the grief and outrage is
more profound is it that hard for the
government to admit it's wrong a doctor
had to die twice that's a national
humiliation and the eyes of the people
are clear his death is the top trending
topic on China's micro blogging site
Weibo one of the most popular hashtags
before being deleted was we want freedom
of speech Lee had been in the front line
of this crisis falling sick from the
virus while treating patients his death
was confirmed on the website of Wuhan
Hospital on Friday morning Lee died
after all rescue efforts said the
statement we express our deep
condolences did an official from China's
National Health Commission the National
Health Commission extends our sincere
condolences and respect to the family
and wife of dr. Lee Wan Liang we know
that for medical workers in the
frontline they sacrificed her own family
life to contribute to this battle
against a virus the society needs to
care more about our medical workers in
December Lee had sought to share
information about his concerns only to
be investigated by police who accused
him of spreading rumors
Lee's passing highlights the huge risks
taken by frontline doctors and nurses
to treat patients a situation made worse
by overcrowded hospitals and an acute
shortage of beds the government appears
to be listening
it's despatched a team of
anti-corruption investigators to Wuhan
to in its words listen to the concerns
of the public and in China today there's
no shortage of people with opinions
about the doctor and the way he was
treated the virus has spread across
China with cases also emerging in two
dozen countries to cruise ships carrying
thousands of holidaymakers have been
placed under quarantine in Hong Kong and
Japan as doctors test all on board for
infection and another ship currently in
the South China Sea has been refused
entry by Japan South Korea and the
Philippines in China the growing public
outrage will worry the leadership as it
threatens to create what they fear most
social unrest Adrian Brown al-jazeera
Hong Kong